let's go Bruce - paper today we have a
special guest say hi hello
[Music]
I can't wait to see how ugly your
character is I'm so excited
what do you mean ugly now - mine looks
like a mine look like a lunch lady who
had a sex change on steroids that Royce
oh I lost connection no no no this has
to work
get it coming back yeah you better come
back it's getting dark where are you I'm
being born
moment I'm scared skip I'm scared I'm
scared don't worry I'm I'm on the I
haven't won why I'm really worried
actually now there's a there's there's a
level 12 guy over here is it is that me
yeah I'm level 12 where are you where
were brother where is he hey hey toran
are you down there
jesus [ __ ] christ
[Music]
I thought though you're a stone you're a
stone that's how ugly you are
that's racist Jesus Christ you're ugly
my god how much inbred created this
monster I'm so big compared to you don't
no no no no don't piss me Dave did you
the ones back your back is like
Quasimodo all right let's get on this
data so boy what you talking about
get on your dad can't get on your Dinah
so you can't get on that I will follow
me okay this way my son okay I'm coming
yeah daddy dad nice my boy I'm gonna
teach you the way of dinosaur hunting
okay stay it's very dangerous
you're so ugly your mom was a [ __ ] yeah
you heard my feeling I'm sorry but it's
the truth mom was a nice beautiful lady
and he loved her I did love her once and
then I came out all right here we go all
right my child you will kill this
dinosaur with your bare fists I just
[ __ ] they just hit look at this [ __ ] boy
do you see this [ __ ] Wow it looks like a
seashell no you're right what do you
[ __ ] maybe I heard someone [ __ ] I swear
to God that that's me sorry I just got
so excited from seeing this down that's
understandable
my boy I defecated you did I'm proud of
you boy yeah pick it up pick it up pick
it up pick it up
show me your [ __ ] Chris I okay and then
okay are you smelling your [ __ ] it is
testing I gotta check it you know make
sure that get no no no I say go good boy
yeah that's my boy that's my we gotta
make sure it's dead
you've been ya Widow be dead well yeah
way to go we're not getting up
way to go it's gone I can't believe it
my god little Timmy
your name is little Timmy yeah yeah dad
you got a nice bulge there it alone
Timmy
Thanks left cheek is so much bigger than
the right one hey hey we're all rotten
food my health is decreasing hey my crap
Timmy why did I talk to you about eating
your [ __ ] not to that's right not to why
is this dinosaur just [ __ ] standing
is it stuck yeah keep punching that
[ __ ] punch it in the [ __ ]
Timmy did you die yeah dad I'll kill you
all event [ __ ] for your bra why do I
have to create a new survivor I died I
died too
Oh No all right let's go through on the
go to the green light do you see a green
light I'm coming straight to you
my perfect summer and past each other
just go through the green light yeah
we're back there's that [ __ ] I never
forget a good [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
right so my backpack should be here
somewhere oh my god no no salad [ __ ] is
dead salad [ __ ] my my favorite dinosaur
he was like a child to me the dead
go away go away let us be alone leave us
okay leave us salad [ __ ]
[Music]
sounds dead
we're having a memorial show some
respect [ __ ] you
solid [ __ ] is dead do you know how much
she meant to me no salad B I got some
battle glasses so you the national
anthem no don't punch am i thought it
moved check - oh I didn't Rob me from
punching him that's awesome yeah [ __ ]
you salad this is amazing little Timmy
is my twin brother now what did we teach
in this family is that we teach this
family are you are you swimming
backwards on your screen
oh yeah I'm sitting back weird you do it
beautiful wow you really have a talent
for that backstroke I've been working on
it am ia little poo ball
now you're yeah well I guess basically I
got
dad no she's died right before all right
well we recover our stuff find out in
the next episode lemon I can be enjoyed
and for every like you save a little
Timmy
yeah little Timmy's life little Jimmy
loves you tell me it's Amy loves here
forever like your name subscribe to
become a little Timmy today and we will
see you in the next one it's always
Jimmy I'm sorry Tina
why do you do it it really can't be hide
yes